[Applaudissements]
tu le va tout changer boîte est pas pour
ça c'est bien beau de chanter mais ça
suffit pas tu devrais m'écouter et
laisser la chanson à quoi pensent donner
c'est juste une passion tu n importe qui
monte redescend d'un étage
tu fais n'importe quoi surtout à son âge
à n'importe quel prix il faut toujours
mais là
il va n'importe quoi
et si moi j'y crois
[Musique]
je
tu peux tout ça
[Musique]
des fois pour sais pas
tu devrais oublier et faire une fausse
on n'est pas au ciné tout n'est pas si
rose où se trouve toi un métier pense à
l'avenir tu veux continuer mais tu as
fini par faire n'importe quoi ton temps
pour n'importe qui écoute à maman qui a
porté son choix
c'est plus important que tout de ses
amplis est-ce que tu m'entends
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
je me sers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le reste est si fort a dit fais moi je
restais séparatif est de rester actif
je n'aurais pas
[Musique]
x
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est en 8 c'était le petit protégé de
soprano les quatre jurys sont retournés
sur vous et soprano il vous aime
tellement qu'il a décidé vous
accompagnez même s'il n'avait pas
remporté l'édition numéro 8 c'est lui
qui a produit on a des anciens candidats
de télé crochet ah oui on sait ce qu a
hélas jean pascal croit devoir faire de
la musique grande fierté parce que
clément et bastiais et on se connaît de
bastian donc grande fierté pour les
corses parce que franchement il
représente la chanson moi j'ai laissé
tomber mais c'est la chanson a laissé
tomber d'accès c'est vrai c'est
impressionnant du devoir du talon qui
chantera bien sûr mais c'est la chanson
très admiratif et surtout quand on se
connaît tous aussi aux pays bas se rend
compte qu'on tournait aussi ça c'est
parce que s'étonner des basses terres du
pays parce que c'est pas vraiment
d'accord alors on a évidemment un petit
message de soprane évidemment qu'on
adore et basse était petit cadeau pour
vous c'est parti salut belge a même
salué benjamin salue toute l'équipe
merci pour clément merci de soutenir mon
ami clément
je crois en lui on en train de
travailler sur son album là à fond moi
je suis pas présent je suis même pas sur
terre je suis dans mon vaisseau dans les
étoiles
donc on vous envoie plein des toiles
pleines de bonne heure on atterrit
bientôt mais en tout cas on fait plein
de bise à vous tous et plein de bonheur
et prendre soin de vous sur terre des
bises c'était son premier
[Applaudissements]
21 j'espère que les fait reculer les
salles pour les gros prêt vous produire
devant votre public